What's up everybody!
We are Pongfinity
Today we will be taking over my university
Hanken School of Economics
A very international business school in Finland
This will be fun!
Thanks!
That was an interesting serve!
Hanken is a triple accredited business school.
That means it has earned all three big quality international labels
Here is a target shot for each one of them!
Triple Crown!
Second one in a row
Around the plants
Hit the cup
Let's go!
Hanken offers a two years master's
program in English
You can study: marketing, finance, economics,
management,
accounting and commercial law.
It was a nice sound!
Now let's check out the classrooms!
This is classroom table tennis!
Let's make Miikka run!
Watch this!
Nice trick shot, Otto!
C'mon!
And this is the Hanken Business Lab
A place for start-ups and entrepreneurs.
That's how you do it!
Huge thanks to Hanken for sponsoring this video
We had a lot of fun filming here!
Finland is a great place to study:
it's a safe country with a lot of friendly people
If you are interested in studying at Hanken
Make sure to check out the link in the description
to find more information about the school!
Until next time!